there doorbell where it does hello
welcome to our little house thank you
yeah come on in
only et was invited inside a southern
charm stars Craig Conover and Naomi oh
Lindos Charleston South Carolina House
for an exclusive home tour to start with
I believe it's the closet okay
higher bedroom we can start with in this
important room yes Craig and Naomi turns
an entire bedroom into a shared walk-in
closet it was vicious
honestly at this point Craig and I are
pretty even way today but she has way
more shoes these are about half of yeah
I don't think any of these are yours
no only on Tuesdays okay hahaha pink
once the home is cozy one bathroom and
two functional bedrooms welcome to our
bedroom race that's where the magic
happens
yeah totally where the magic happens all
the sleeping that is magic oh hey guys
well oh yes my has arrived oh my god you
let me pick like is this the real king
of this house yeah is this your better
gizmo spit it's mixed I think he
answered that question this is Craig
sewing room yep Craig has his own sewing
station and a whole workshop in the
garage all right so this is kind of my
area
um there's face only just I mean you
could come out here too out here he's
growing plants and working on projects
for the couple's new house which they're
renovating just down the street
Naomi's commissioned me to build the
shutters for new house and this is the
look that she's commissioned so they
need to retire yeah again of course we
had to check out that new house it's the
same layout just improved so come on in
to Craig and Amy's house a 2.0 Wow
yeah so we're getting there it's been
under construction for over a year
there's the upgraded kitchen there's the
best part and yes in ultra luxe a master
suite complete with an actual closet
Wow
so this actually is our closet so it's
going to be split into two one sizing me
my side the other side will be Craig so
I don't have to deal with his mess
anymore
[Music]